la toute première image de vous date de
1981 et c'est un soir de victoire
électorale vous n'êtes pas encore dans
la lumière mais dans l'ombre d'un
candidat dont vous êtes le directeur de
cabinet claude germond le maire
socialiste de massy qui vient de sortir
le communiste pierre juquin dans la
troisième circonscription de l'essonne
vous avez 30 ans
[Musique]
claude germain vient proclamer les voix
obtenues dans sa ville
trente ans pas encore de demande d'amm
et déjà de l'ambition politique
ouais je l'ambition si vous voulez ça
j'étais un militant très très engagé
pour qui le militantisme politique est
une raison de vivre
et se trouve que je militais avec un
homme qui était extrêmement motivant il
était secrétaire confédérale de la cgt
et secrétaire national aux entreprises
pour le ps et donc sa manière d'être son
rapport au mouvement ouvrier
était pour moi un repère il était il a
été un repère immense dans ma vie c'est
tout à fait évident et puis nous
partagions une certitude qu'ils veulent
peut-être vous surprendre on pensait
réellement qu'on allait faire le
socialisme donc si vous voulez les
questions du type carrière post s'était
pas vraiment le sujet
[Musique]